starting off this hours Des Moines Iowa
Laurie is with us hi Lori how are you hi
fave I'm okay that's been better but I
still feel blessed how are you
just the same better than I deserve how
can I help well try and make a long
story short I am married have been
married for five years and I went
through Financial Peace University the
first part of the year and I just
started going again this last this last
week and I have been carrying a very big
secret about my debt with my husband and
this week I finally came clean with him
he's a very understanding person but I
see and feel that he's very very
disappointed in me
and the trust issue is is a big issue
and I'm I want him to come to Financial
Peace University with me I can't
convince me to do that he said he is
very well with his money he does very
good with it investing saving in the
hole er
he says this is something that I need to
do because this is my problem and I just
don't know where to turn um where was
the debt from from before you were
married you it just never gone it's kind
of distilled all the time there was a
small amount of debt before I got
married but I will tell you I have two
children from a previous marriage and I
have been one of those parents that help
them out whenever I feel they need help
and I have to go into the financial
piece the first time I stopped doing
that for the most part um my daughter
was sick today she was actually in the
hospital and I I'm at her apartment I
had to buy her medicine because she had
no medicine for this from getting out of
the hospital so I mean it wasn't much
but I still helped her out today and I'm
going to tell my husband everything that
I spend with her today I'm not keeping
any secrets from him anymore at this
point so how much debt have you run up
about twelve thousand and what do you
make a year that makes about forty
thousand and what does he make a year it
forty-thousand okay well I mean there's
never a good time and you know that to
to hide something and that never builds
trust and never builds a quality
relationship you're aware of that and so
I and this is tied to you medicating
these kid issues with money and it's
causing that I get that and and yet I
will tell you that while I if we had to
put percentages on this I would put 90%
of it on you
I put 10% of it on him and the reason is
is he's absolutely no help to his wife
it's absolutely absurd he just stands
back and looks at you like you're a
roommate and says you need to get your
life straightened up this is his wife
and I'm not okay I'm fine with him being
upset with you for hiding this and lying
to him about it I'm fine with him
feeling a lack of trust because of the
trust was broken I got no issue with
that at all that will take time to heal
but but I'm not fine with him standing
over the side for five years and saying
that's your problem deal with it that's
not a good way to run a marriage it's
not a good way to run a relationship and
so he helped in other ways as far as you
know he lets me do whatever I do this is
another thing I probably should mention
you just said that your he lets you do I
don't let Sharon Ramsey do anything
shouldn't let me do anything
we make decisions together about what we
are going to do I don't need her
permission she need my permission but we
have made a decision to work together
and to make decisions together about
what we are going to do so I think you
guys have got some work to do on that
and I think it's going to help your
marriage overall because it probably is
in more areas than just in the just in
the the money area or the hidden debt
area I think there's more to it than
that so I guess you need to approach him
and maybe you know maybe have your
pastor and you sit down with him and you
guys talk through some of these this
broken trust and some of the anger
associated with that but he also needs
to commit
to helping his wife and that means
joining forces with his wife to live
life together and and yeah that does
include going to class because his
wife's going to class if he goes to
class because he can learn one thing and
you can learn 10 but we get on the same
page that's a good reason to go to class
perfectly state that's perfectly to say
that what I'm trying to convince them of
is that even though I need the teaching
I need him to pack me and now it was him
it was I and now it's we example
together together exactly and you guys
are really missing out on something here
and a good way for you to rebuild trust
is not to have to call in every receipt
but that we lay out a budget with our
money together and then we stick to that
budget and the longer you do that
the more this wound in your relationship
where you were deceiving him heals and
you know in our in our marriage is the
same way not from deception but from
stupidity on steroids when I wrecked
everything Sharron didn't have any say
it all into the marriage I mean into the
money and so you know 25 years ago I
I ran the financial car in the creek and
it took her a while to trust my
financial judgment after that and to
this day if we go into certain areas of
a discussion 25 years later and still a
tender spot but it's less tender this
year than it was five years ago and
certainly less tender than it was 20
years ago so you know over time it heals
but there will always be this this
question and so you put in place
promises and that you keep and systems
to like doing a budget together to be on
the same page and to communicate and to
trust each other and that's exactly how
you do this yes he needs to get involved
he needs to get involved and you guys
need to be running the budget together
and that way you can heal a lot of
different things that are going on in
this situation hey thanks for the call